[MUSIC PLAYING]
UMESH SHANKAR: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thanks for coming
to our session.
My name is Umesh Shankar.
I'm a principal
engineer at Google
based in our New York office.
I'm the technical lead
for Access Transparency.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Umesh.
And my name is Joseph Valente.
I'm a product manager, also
based in our New York office.
And I'm the PM for
Access Transparency.
So it takes a tremendous
amount of trust
to put your data on
the public cloud.
And it's very difficult
to gain that trust
when you don't have full
visibility over what's
happening to your data.
And so that's why,
today, we're really
excited to talk about
Access Transparency.
It's a new product
only available on GCP,
and it gives you full visibility
over what happens to your data
on the cloud.
So we know that companies
in every industry
are increasingly using
software and data to change
the way that they do business.
This isn't just true for
companies in the technology
and finance and other
industries that have used
software for a very long time.
It's also true for
businesses in manufacturing,
in logistics, and
even in mining,
where we're seeing lots of
companies that previously never
even hired a software
engineer, now, running
multiple teams at scale,
deploying software
to production daily.
And the public cloud is very
important in these situations
because it gives
you the flexibility.
It gives you the ability
to manage your costs.
And it also gives you the
availability of technology
that you need in order
to facilitate that shift.
Now, at Google we know a lot
about building great software
teams.
Over the last few
years, we've built
seven separate businesses,
each with over a billion users
on them.
And in order to
do this, we needed
to build a phenomenal
internal cloud.
The internal cloud we
built out is the same one
that we make available to you
through Google Cloud Platform.
And it combines incredible
enterprise-grade reliability
with super-fast
compute and storage
as well as security
and compliance.
And in order to do this, we had
to completely reinvent the way
that the data center
works from the ground up.
And we've done such an
incredible job of it
that now people, instead
of going and checking
whether their
internet works, just
go to google.com, because they
assume that Google will be up.
And we're really,
really happy to be
able to offer this to you.
There's a saying
as well that says
that anyone who's serious
about making software
makes their own
hardware as well.
And at Google,
we're obviously very
serious about making
software, which is
why we make our own hardware.
And that's what you can see
on the screen right now.
This is one of our custom
Tensor Processing Unit chips.
It's completely designed
in-house by Google,
and it's available to you to
use on Google Cloud Platform.
Why did we build this chip?
Because we wanted
to take machine
learning to the next level.
We wanted to completely
optimize the experience
of running machine learning
computations in a data center.
And this chip is 15
to 30 times faster
than a conventional
processor for machine
learning applications.
Think about being seven
years in the future in terms
of what you're able to
do with your computer.
That's what we can
do with this chip.
Now, how do we use this
internally at Google?
We use machine
learning at Google
to actually invest in how we
cool our own data centers.
Data center cooling is a really,
really complicated thing.
You need to take into
account the weather outside,
the heat of the data center.
You need to take into
account the pumps
and the pipes and the ducts.
And it's a really complicated
equation for a human to solve.
So we set up a machine
learning classifier.
And we asked to optimize all
the variables in the equation.
And we were able to cut the
costs of cooling our data
centers by 40%.
It was a drop that was so
big, that we thought there was
an error in the calculation.
But we're excited that
you guys will also
be able to do this in
your own businesses
using things like the
TPU only on Google Cloud.
But being on the
cloud means having
people to run the
cloud, people who
are going to help you achieve
that level of reliability,
achieve that level of
usability, and achieve
that level of security.
And very specifically, in the
case of Google Cloud Platform,
it's these people--
not these specific three people,
because we have slightly more
than that running--
people working on
Google Cloud today--
but Google Cloud
software engineers
is what I meant to say.
And these people
are the people who
are responsible for making sure
that your service is always
reliable.
It's always up and
running when you need it.
And part of working with a new
group of software engineers
is developing a new
relationship of trust.
So in your on-prem environment,
you probably had vendors.
You had employees.
You had people who were
working to make sure
that your systems were reliable.
And you developed a
relationship of trust
with these people over
a long period of time.
Moving to the public
cloud is no different.
It just involves you entering
into a new relationship
of trust with a new
group of people.
And that's what we hope to
give you a bit more information
about in today's talk.
So far, I've spoken
about cloud migration.
I've talked about
how important it
is to changing the way
people do business--
the flexibility,
the reliability,
the cost management.
And I've spoken about big
data and machine learning,
how exciting that is, and
how many opportunities that's
going to open up for all
of us in every business
in every industry.
And I've also started to talk
a little bit about security
compliance and trust.
Now, the challenge for you today
is that these three big themes
can't be tackled independently.
Every business is trying
to do all these things
at the same time.
And that's very, very difficult
in a changing environment.
And it really, really helps
to have a cloud provider
that you can trust, that
they're investing in security
and compliance to bring you up
to speed at the rate you need.
And that's going to be the
focus of today's presentation.
So before we can enjoy all
these incredible benefits
of being on the cloud, we need
to get a few things right.
Security-- "Am I
secure in the cloud?"
A recent survey by
HyTrust of cloud buyers
globally found that the top-two
fears of people purchasing
cloud were malicious
or accidental exposure
of workload data and
uncontrolled or unmonitored
access by admins.
I want you to think
about those two things
because we're going to come
back and touch on them later
in this presentation.
Compliance-- "Can I meet
my compliance obligations?"
Now, this is not
just about compliance
with external
policies that you may
have to comply with or
external certifications.
It's also about compliance
with your own internal policies
and being able to have
visibility and certainty
that you can certify that those
things have been abided by.
And finally, trust--
"Can I trust my cloud provider?"
This is related to
security and compliance,
but it's slightly different.
This is more of an
emotional thing.
Is the person that I'm in
business with along with me
for the journey to
make me successful?
So these are the three
needs that we need in order
to move onto the cloud.
But the way that
we see it at Google
is that, in order to
meet these three needs,
we need three foundational
pillars in place--
technology, operations,
and accountability.
And to talk to you more
about these three pillars,
I'm going to invite Umesh.
UMESH SHANKAR: Thanks, Joe.
First thing we're going to
talk about is technology.
If you don't have a
secure technology stack
from the ground up, nothing
else really matters.
No amount of operations,
no amount of accountability
is going to save you if your
data is not fundamentally safe.
We look at this problem as
a series of layers, right?
You have your hardware
at the bottom.
You have it all the way up
through your application layer
at the top-- the
software that's actually
running on the platform.
And we've actually invested
in every one of these layers
to make it secure, to harden it,
and to address all those three
aspects that Joe talked about.
So let's start at the bottom.
We're going to dive
into each one in turn.
It used to be the case,
and by and large, still
is true that, if you
order a piece of hardware,
you get it as the
manufacturer intended it.
Unfortunately, it's
not always true.
And there have
been real attacks,
in the wild, where the supply
chain has been compromised.
So you're a company.
You order a piece of hardware,
maybe, a network card
as shown in this picture.
And it shows up with malware
already installed on the card.
Maybe the firmware
has already been
compromised because
someone inserted themselves
in the supply chain.
This is a real
thing that happens.
And it's something that we,
actually, very actively worry
about at Google.
We've taken steps to directly
address this problem.
We've actually
developed a custom chip,
which we call Titan--
which gives us a hardware root
of trust for both machines
and peripherals.
So on this network card,
which is the kind of thing
you might find in
any of our machines
in our production
network, there's
actually this little Titan
chip on that card today.
And what that does is
allows us to verify
the integrity of all the
firmware and other components
that are on the card.
So when it comes
online, we know it
hasn't been tampered with
relative to where it started.
So as you might imagine, we have
a lot of machines at Google.
And you can see them represented
by these little boxes.
Unfortunately, I'm not
allowed to say exactly how
many machines we have.
I'm allowed to give you a range.
So it's somewhere between
100 and 10 billion.
That, I can tell you.
And each one of those machines
can be in a different state,
right?
So some might have
just been booted up.
Some might be running
some software.
Some might have been
online for a while
and are at older
version of software.
How do you kind of
manage these things
and make sure that things are
in a good state over time?
Again, here, if we look at what
it takes to start up a machine,
you turn it on, you load the
BIOS that loads the bootloader
and so forth.
We've actually taken steps
at each stage of this process
to harden each thing.
So we use Titan at
power-on time to make sure
that the next thing
is loaded correctly.
We do our own custom
BIOS where we've actually
hardened it and made sure
there's no extraneous software.
We've done the same
thing for the bootloader.
We've done the same thing
for the Linux kernel.
So we actually pare
away all the parts
of the kernel we
don't actually, really
need to run things
in our data centers.
And we actively contribute
security improvements
to the kernel itself.
And finally, the OS
image, the software
that runs as a base
image on the platform
is something that's very
carefully managed and curated.
At the same time, we keep a
cryptographic, trusted boot
chain as each stage is loaded.
So we start from
Titan at the bottom.
We get the BIOS next.
And as the BIOS
loads the bootloader,
and the bootloader
starts the kernel,
each one signs the next thing.
And what's so important
about this is,
when the process is
complete, we know
that each step was genuine.
No one could have
changed or inserted
something along the way.
A really fundamental
concept in the way
that we think about security
is that of identity.
To run a cloud, to run a data
center, you need services,
you need machines,
and you need people.
And we assign each
one of these things
in Identity in our system.
So we just saw all the
steps that a machine has
to go through in order to boot.
Well, what we do is, we only
assign a machine in Identity
at the end of that process.
And because virtually
everything works
by one thing talking
to another thing
over some
communications channel,
if you don't have
that identity, you
don't get to talk
to anything else.
So only authentic machines
even get to talk to anything.
Similarly, we apply
the same philosophy
to services and to people.
For people to get
an identity, they
have to pass both a
two-factor authentication
check, which involves a
secure hardware second factor.
And they have to be coming
from a trusted managed device.
And if they don't
pass those things,
they don't get an
identity, which
means they can't
talk to machines,
and they can't talk to services,
which, effectively, means
they can't do
anything interesting,
which is as it should be.
We actually, as it turns out,
do the same thing for services
as well.
And we're going to come back
to that in a couple minutes.
You'll see how we have the
same notion of identity
for a service and how we
make that notion strong.
So we talked about how
communication is constant.
Each of these kinds of things
are talking to the other
during the normal
operation of a data center.
And each link is
strongly authenticated.
So when we say
identity, we actually
mean giving something a
cryptographic certificate
that contains its identity.
And so whenever you have a
link, where one thing is talking
to another, one party
always has a strong idea
of who the other party is.
And it can use that
to make decisions
about whether it's what
it expected, what it's
allowed to do, and so forth.
All right.
So we've got our data
center up and running.
We've given
identities to things.
They're communicating.
Things are starting to work.
We're getting some
data in the door.
How do we manage that data?
Well, one of the most basic
and important things we can do
is make sure that
data stays encrypted
both in transit and at rest.
All the data coming from
you, as customers, to Google
is protected with TLS.
So it's encrypted
in transit there.
And then, within the data
center and between data centers,
we actually use a combination
of hardware and software
encryption to make sure it stays
encrypted across network links.
When we're about
to store the data--
in other words, to
repose the data--
we actually take it, and
we encrypt it in chunks
with different encryption keys.
And this kind of ties back to
what we looked at a moment ago.
Then the question becomes,
who gets to decrypt the data?
Who gets to have the key?
And so our highly-secure
Key Management System
will only hand keys for,
let's say, Cloud Bigtable
data to the service that
manages Cloud Bigtable.
And it knows it's that
service because it
has a very specific identity.
The Cloud Bigtable
Service's identity
is distinct from that of
all the other software.
And that's how we make
sure that data only flows
in the appropriate direction.
So I said a minute ago that we
have this notion of identity
for services as well.
And this is really critical to
the way that our whole system
functions.
So let's come back to our
example of Cloud Bigtable data.
You create a Cloud
Bigtable incidents.
We store that somewhere.
Access to that data in
storage is tightly guarded
by an Access Control List.
And we'll list all the machines,
people, services-- anything
that's allowed to access
it must appear there,
or the access is not allowed.
So let's say we
have the system that
actually serves Cloud Bigtable
data back to you as the user.
That needs to appear here.
But what does it mean?
How do we know what things
ought to be in that list?
What distinguishes the
Cloud Bigtable serving code
from any other code?
The answer is, we have a system
called Binary Authorization
which is quite novel and
actually, as of today, it's
something that you
can start to play
with on Kubernetes on cloud.
And what it does is it lets us
tie those production service
identities to specific
pieces of code and processes
by which that code is
managed and deployed.
So in our particular
example, we would
say we only want to put
the Cloud Bigtable service
identity on the ACL if it
was built from the particular
build target in our
source repository
that corresponds to the Cloud
Bigtable serving system.
And we want to know
that all that code that
went in there was reviewed by
a second person so one engineer
couldn't make a mistake and
screw the whole thing up.
We want to make sure that
code was built by our trusted
build system.
We want to make sure
that it was released
in accordance with our
mandated release process.
Binary Authorization lets
us do all these things.
And in fact, we do do them.
So for somebody to get
access to that user data,
it has to pass all these steps.
It has to be code that was
purpose-built to do this one
thing.
It has to have been reviewed,
it has to have been built,
it has to have been deployed
in a proper fashion.
And finally, it has to present
that strong cryptographic
identity.
This is the kind of
thing that gives us
confidence in the overall
operation of the system.
So I've given you, actually,
a pretty brief overview
of our tech stack.
If you're interested
to learn more,
and you want to get more
details and information,
there's actually a fairly
detailed technical white paper
on our site.
If you go to
cloud.google.com/security,
it's called the Security
Infrastructure Whitepaper.
So I'd encourage anyone who's
interested in learning more
to take a look.
All right, so that's
the technology part.
But as Joe said earlier, you
can't run an entire cloud just
with technology.
You need to have operations.
You need people to
improve the service,
to maintain the service,
to provide support.
And our thinking is
that defensive controls
start in the data center.
That's literally where the data
is, so you have to protect it.
And the first line of defense
is physical security, right?
We actually have multiple
layers of defense.
We actually have armed guards.
We have retina scanning.
We have fingerprint scanning.
And I know, because
I've actually
been to a data center floor.
And let me tell you, it is very
hard to get onto that floor
if you're not supposed
to be there, especially,
past those laser beams.
We have a strict access
management system.
And what that does is it
says, these specific kinds
of people, in these
specific job roles
are allowed onto the
floor at specific times
for a specific reason, right?
So again, it's difficult
to get onto the floor
to even be near the machines
where the data lives,
unless you have a very
good reason to be there,
and we know what you're doing.
And finally, we
retrospectively look
at who, in fact, was out
there, why they were there.
And we audit that to
make sure that everything
was appropriate.
JOSEPH VALENTE:
Did you have to get
past the laser beams to
get on the floor as well?
UMESH SHANKAR: I did.
I did.
I studied contortionism
for about six months.
But if you've seen the
movie "Mr. & Mrs. Smith,"
it was a lot like that.
JOSEPH VALENTE: OK, cool.
UMESH SHANKAR: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So we said that we need people
to administer our cloud, right?
And that means that
those people themselves
can become targets, right?
If I'm an attacker, if I want
to gain access to Google's data,
how am I going to do it?
Well, I might go after someone
who works at Google, right?
So to protect our employees,
we use those two techniques
I mentioned before.
We have phishing-resistant
hardware authentication
in the form of security keys,
which is something we recommend
that everybody use.
And it's something
which, on cloud,
you can actually mandate that
all your employees use as well.
And we mandate the use of
managed access devices.
So you can't just pick
up a random laptop
and start debugging
Google Cloud software.
You have to come from a
specific device that's
been provisioned by Google and
managed to be in a good state.
OK.
So you're a person at Google.
You need to do some support
work or administrative work.
We still want to make sure
that only the right people have
access to things,
and they're only
doing things for
the right reason.
So here, too, we have
role-based access controls.
If you don't work on Cloud
Bigtable in a support role,
you're not going
to ever have access
to Cloud Bigtable resources.
Our support tools
are purpose-built.
So if you work in support,
the only way for you
to gain access to, say,
metadata about a Bigtable
is to use this support tool.
And the support
tool will require
you to say why you're
doing something.
So if you can't produce the
specific customer support
ticket, as an example--
that is the thing that you're
following up on to access
that specific resource--
you're not going to get access.
And finally, again, we employ
auditing very extensively.
It's a good way
for us to make sure
that people are using that
access appropriately all
the time.
So let's come back
to that question
that Joe raised early on.
"Am I secure in the cloud?"
I mean, I can't answer
that question for you.
But I can say--
and hopefully, you
have a sense now--
that we have made an enormous
investment in security.
We have, I think,
over 900 people
working on security
and privacy alone.
And the only way that
we're able to make
this kind of an
investment is because we
operate at such a large scale.
It actually makes financial
sense for us to do this.
We have so much at stake.
And we can amortize that
cost over a very large number
of machines.
Now, this is something that
customers can do on their own
in part.
But it's very
expensive to do that.
So we actually think
that, for most customers,
they're going to end up having
the same or better security
as they move to a public
cloud by taking advantage
of these kind of sophisticated
features that we've built.
So that actually brings us
to pillar number three--
accountability.
It's well and good
for me to talk to you
about our technology,
for me to talk
to you about our operations,
for us to publish whitepapers.
I think these are actually
all very important things.
We're trying to be as open and
transparent as we can about
how we run our cloud so you can
have that as a basis for trust.
But we think it's
really important, too,
to give you direct
accountability.
What is Google actually doing?
Why are they doing it?
And the reason we think
that's so important
is we have to hold
ourselves accountable.
We understand why
this is so important.
When you run a
system like Gmail,
you worry about accidental
exposure of data.
You worry about unmonitored
access by admins.
This is something that
we do all the time.
And the way we hold ourselves
accountable beyond all
those access controls,
which I mentioned, is we
have these robust internal logs.
We collect detailed logs of
whenever people at Google
do things, we funnel them
into a central location,
and we apply very
sophisticated techniques
to try to detect if anything
was being done inappropriately.
If we didn't have
those kind of controls,
we couldn't feel comfortable
running those kinds of services
and feeling like they
were actually secure.
So it's a fair
question, as a customer
to say, all right,
well, you want
me to trust you to run my
business on Google Cloud.
But I don't have access to
those same internal logs
that you have.
How am I supposed
to feel comfortable?
Well, it's exactly to
answer that question
that I'm really excited to
announce Access Transparency.
It's a new product
offering on GCP.
It's something that
you're not going
to find on any other cloud.
And the point of it is to
give you meaningful oversight
of your cloud provider.
We're going to give
you near real-time logs
when a person at Google
accesses your content.
We think this is a
really important step
in establishing trust
with you, the customer,
and giving you a basis
on which you can build
a secure business in the cloud.
And I think the best
way to understand
the concept behind
Access Transparency
is to look at an example.
By far, the most common
reason anyone at Google
would ever have to access
customer content is
for support.
It's when we're asked to do so.
So let's look at an example.
This is the kind of thing
that certainly happens.
A customer is a user of our
Google Cloud Storage API.
They try to read one of
the objects in a bucket,
and the data looks
corrupted, and they're not
able to figure out what was
going on, so they call support.
Now, that action by
the customer admin
will generate a Cloud Audit Log.
So when we talk
about accountability,
there's layers of
accountability.
So as a customer,
you want to keep tabs
on what your own
admins are doing.
And Cloud Audit Logging
lets you do that.
You could see that
someone was trying
to read this particular object.
So now let's look
at the next level.
They contacted Google Support.
And so the support
person goes in.
They're not able to access
the content of the object,
because that's just not allowed
by our policy in general.
But they are able to access
things like the Access Control
List.
Because sometimes maybe
the problem is there,
or maybe it's with
other metadata,
and they can figure it out
without having to go deeper.
But in this case,
everything looks fine.
They had to say why they did it.
It was to handle this particular
customer support ticket--
12345.
And it all looks fine.
And they're going to have
to escalate to engineering.
Now, before Access
Transparency, this
is what you would get
to see as a customer
when that access occurred--
pretty much a gray box, right?
That's not very
satisfying, right?
With Access Transparency,
it looks very different.
You're going to get a
log in near real time--
so we're talking
minutes, not days--
of what specific
thing was accessed.
And you can see here.
It's the particular
object that was accessed.
And at the end, you
can see it was just
the ACL, not the content
of the object itself.
You get to see what type
of action was performed,
and you get to see the reason
for that access, right?
Because the point
of this is to say,
yes, I can account for
each thing that occurred.
This makes sense to me.
I understand why it happened.
So let's go to the
next level, right?
We couldn't resolve the
problem with support.
We had to get
engineering involved.
And engineering has access to
lower-level debugging tools
than support
typically does, right?
So they can actually go
into the underlying systems
where the things live.
They can use the internal
APIs to try to pull more data,
to figure out what's going on.
All right.
So in this case,
again, the engineer
has to say a justification.
So they're doing it
for this reason--
this particular ticket number.
And they're able to get
the data and say, OK, I
see what happened.
The data had a
different encoding
than the one that you
thought, and that's
why the data appeared
to be corrupted.
We're able to recover.
And so everything is good,
notify the customer, great.
Importantly, you're going to get
another log when this happens.
And this time, you
can actually see
that the content of the
object was accessed, right?
That's the level of
granularity and transparency we
think is really important
for us to offer.
I'd like to spend just
one more minute talking
about what I like to
call deep transparency
versus shallow transparency.
So I mentioned that
support accounts
for the vast majority of
accesses, that support
requested by the customer is--
I don't know the exact figures.
But it's like 80%, 90%,
something like that.
And so that seems like,
oh, it's not that hard.
We have a purpose-built
support tool.
Let's go instrument the tool,
we'll get some logs, and we'll?
Send them over to the
customer, no big deal, right?
And that is definitely way
better than nothing, right?
It turns out, actually, not
to be that easy, in the end,
but you could do it.
We decided to go beyond that.
We wanted to say, OK, even
though we could give you
80% of the logs for 10% of the
effort, that doesn't really
fulfill the point
of this feature.
The point of this
feature is to tell you
as much as possible about every
time that someone at Google
accessed your content.
And so we wanted to get
those deeper access points,
those internal APIs, those
low-level general purpose
storage systems to be
part of the solution too.
Now, it turns out there
is way more code--
there are a lot more systems
there than in our support
system, right?
It's an order of magnitude
more stuff, maybe even more.
And it only gives us 10%, 5% of
the logs, something like that.
But it felt like the
right thing to do.
And that's the kind
of thing that we're
hoping to do going forward and
bring it to all of GCP for you.
OK.
With that, I'm going to
hand it back over to Joe
to show you a demo of
the system in action.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks, Umesh.
OK.
So let's take a look at how
Access Transparency would
actually work in real life.
So let's slow this down a little
bit so it's easier for everyone
here to see.
I'm going to slow it
down to half speed.
Ooh, I don't want to do that.
And so I'm going to go ahead.
And I'm going to
open up a bucket.
And I'm going to try
and access the file.
And I get this
error, "Permission
denied on Cloud KMS key."
So that's not good.
I'm going to go and
contact support and see
if they can help me out.
So this is not exactly what
the support person sees,
but it's, roundabout, exactly
how the experience works.
Support person inserts
this justification.
It says case number 202123.
Now try and remember that
case number, because it's
going to come back later.
I'm not testing you.
So they insert
that justification,
and it's checked.
It says, OK, this person
has that ticket open.
I'm going to give them access.
And they actually end up saying
to you there was this issue,
and you fix it, and the
data is showing up fine,
so that's great.
So you're going to say,
OK, I fixed my issue.
Let me go to the Logging panel
and see what logs showed up.
And now, you can see that,
in the Logging panel,
there's Access
Transparency logs available
because you contacted support.
So we can go ahead and
bring those logs up.
And I'm going to
expand this panel
because I want to see a little
bit more detail about what's
inside these logs.
I'm going to pick this log here.
I go and take a closer
look, and there it is.
I've got information about
exactly what happened.
And most importantly,
here, I've got the reason.
So there is that case
number again, 202123--
so the full, sort of audit
pathway showing me everything.
Best of all, it works
with all my features
in Stackdriver Logging.
So I can set up metrics,
I can set up alerting,
I can get it to
send me an email.
And we have another session
on this tomorrow morning,
Sect 211 at 9:00 AM if you want
to learn more about how exactly
this can be accomplished.
But for now, the only
important thing to know
is it works just like any
other log on Stackdriver.
So that was a little
bit hard to see.
So maybe let's jump out of this.
And let's take a look at--
let's maybe maximize that.
Let's take a look at this log
in a little bit more detail.
So I want to zoom in to the top
part of our Access Transparency
log and just talk through
the information that's
contained inside it.
So the first line there is Type.
And you can clearly see that
it says Transparency Log.
Why is that useful?
If we want to go ahead and
set up alerts or monitoring
on these particular
types of logs,
if we want to go and fire off an
email to an auditor that says,
please check exactly
what happened every time
we see one of these things, we
can use this field to match,
so we can see that it's
a Transparency log.
The second section gives
a bit more information
about the Google employee
who made the access.
So you can clearly
see here that we've
got the principalOfficeCountry
that the person is typically
located in.
We also have the
principalPhysica
lLocationCountry.
So that is a special
field that is
going to tell you exactly where
the person making the access
was at the time that
the access was made.
We've got some
special technology
that allows us to be able
to make that determination.
And then it also, tells us the
employing entity of the Google.
So it tells us here that
that Google employee
works for the Google LLC.
That's our American entity.
And this might be useful for you
if you have specific, sort of,
governance risk and
compliance needs
for this particular information.
So the second part of the log.
This gives a bit
more information
about exactly what was accessed.
So here you can
see Cloud Storage.
There was a read executed on it.
And the resource name was
this particular bucket, /acl,
which means Access Control List.
So I can identify that
the person in question
didn't look at the content.
They were looking at the Access
Control List of this object.
And finally, reason--
so I can see here
that the reason is given.
It's clearly specified
what the case number is.
And I can go ahead and
pull that case number up
and perform an audit against it
to see if it's what I expected.
If I opened up a
ticket that said,
please investigate why I
can't access my Cloud Storage,
and then I had a
bunch of all these
logs going on, and on,
and on, and on for days,
I might be like,
why did that happen?
So that gives you
that audit trail
that is able to connect
everything together.
You'll notice that there's
also another field called Type.
So the Type specifies that it
is a customer-initiated support
access.
And as Umesh mentioned,
the absolute vast majority
of all the accesses
are customer-initiated.
But there are a few cases
in which they may not be.
In our documentation,
which you can find online,
we talk a little
bit more in detail
about exactly why we might
otherwise access your data.
So I spoke about
customer-initiated support.
You contact us.
You say, hey, I need
some help with something.
That's the most common one.
There's also
Google-initiated service.
Now, this is, by far, the
second-most common one.
And it's where there's
a bug, or an outage,
or some issue where we detect
that there's a problem,
and we need to go and fix it.
Then there's third-party
data request.
And that's to do with things
like court-ordered accesses
or legal accesses.
And finally, there's
Google-initiated review.
And that's to do with things
like abuse or security reviews.
And I note that you may
have custom terms that
allow you to opt out of some of
those particular review cases.
I'm not going to go into
detail and read all of these.
I'd encourage you to head to
our documentation to learn more.
But I just wanted to highlight
that if one of these four
reasons isn't present, then the
data will never be accessed.
So Access Transparency--
what are the key features?
What does it cover?
Think about it as covering
all the data you give us.
So unless it's a public
resource identifier,
like a GCS bucket name, we will
give you an Access Transparency
log when it gets accessed.
And that's important because
Even something as small
as the name of a VM,
or a label that you've
attached to a VM,
we're going to treat that
like it's your customer data.
And we're going to give
you a log of it whenever
it's accessed.
And we did that
because we didn't
want to make value
judgments about what
it is that you find to be
important or not important.
We just want to give
you as much transparency
as we can over your
content and then what's
happening to it on the cloud.
Timeliness-- you're going to get
these logs in near real time.
As Umesh said, it's
minutes, not days.
Availability-- you can get it
through Stackdriver Logging,
as we saw.
And you can also get it
through our Cloud Logging APIs
and through a new offering
from SAP called Data Custodian.
These logs have
audit-grade protections.
So similar to your
audit logs, you
can't delete them unless
you delete the project
or the organization.
That gives you that
extra protection
that a bad actor hasn't
gone in and removed
records of what's happened.
And retention-- we hold
them for free for 13 months.
Now, some additional
important details
are that Access
Transparency logs
cover human accesses through
support and debugging pathways.
So in these cases, you'll
get your real-time logs.
Accesses that are made pursuant
to legal investigations
will typically surface
in near real time.
However, there
may be cases where
we're prohibited, by law,
from servicing those,
and they won't show up.
Then there's system access.
And these are things
like indexing jobs.
But they could be other
jobs that run in our system.
As Umesh explained before, we
have this comprehensive system
of binary authorization
that verifies
that the code that's touching
this data in Bigtable
comes from the Bigtable service.
And because of
those controls, we
don't generate Access
Transparency logs
in those cases because we have
Binary Authorization in place.
And then, finally, accesses
to very low-level storage
systems--
these are extremely rare--
haven't seen one yet, but these
are not real time at present.
There's a human in the
loop at the moment.
We will have real-time
availability, though, in Q4.
So you may be asking, at
this point, what's new?
We've already detailed the fact
that we don't access your data
for reasons other than
necessary to provide you
a service in our
terms of service.
And what Access
Transparency just does
is give you another
layer of visibility
over that commitment.
And it's part of a long list
of transparency commitments
we've been making at
Google over many years.
These include our
tech whitepapers
that you can go ahead
and read to learn
about how our platform works,
our compliance certifications.
We have a transparency
report we've been
publishing for over a decade.
We were the first to start
doing this, and that details
everything about government
and legal actions,
logs of your own
admins on your service
through Cloud Audit
Logging, and now, finally,
logs of Google admins
through Access Transparency.
Access Transparency will be
in general availability coming
very soon.
It will be available for Compute
Engine, Persistent Disk, Cloud
Storage, App Engine,
Cloud IAM, and KMS.
It's available to Platinum
and Gold customers only
or your equivalent in
Role-Based Support.
And you can enable it
today on the GCP website.
Just go to google.com and
search "Access Transparency."
And it should come
up first, I hope.
So thanks very much.
To find out more, you
can head to our website.
And I'm now going to invite
Liz Vasquez, the head of cloud
security at HSBC, on stage
to talk a couple of questions
about how HSBC is using
Access Transparency.
AUDIENCE: Google that.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Google
that and let me know.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Yeah, sure.
OK, thanks for joining us, Liz.
UMESH SHANKAR: Thanks, Liz.
LIZ VASQUEZ: Hello.
JOSEPH VALENTE: So Liz, we
heard a little bit yesterday
in the keynote about how HSBC
is moving a lot of your big data
stuff and many
other applications
onto Google Cloud Platform.
But as a big part of
that, transparency
was important in
making that move.
So can you talk to us about
why Access Transparency was
so important for you?
LIZ VASQUEZ: Right.
To that point, so my
job is cloud security.
So as my company is
moving our data to Google,
I am the one that
needs to look at,
what are all the controls
we have in place?
So we're looking at all the type
of attack vectors, attack paths
that we have.
Google is providing us
tons of access controls
at network layers, access
controls from our admins,
as you said, all the Cloud
Audit Logging we had.
But there was a space where--
that's where the trust comes in.
And the question kept
coming up where--
well, what if our data
is accessed by someone
that's not within our control?
So HSBC can control
or is looking
at all of the actions
of our employees, right?
We are limiting the roles.
We're limiting what
people can and cannot do,
what buckets they can access.
So this was the
last area of trust
for us-- is, well, what
if our buckets, which
have this highly private
and restricted data,
are accessed by Google?
And then the question
comes up, well,
don't you trust them, right?
Oh, this is Google, after all.
And yes, we do trust them.
But that's where we always
say, in security, is trust,
but verify, right?
So Access Transparency
is really helping
us to be able to
tell the auditors,
listen, this is why
we're going to the cloud.
These are all the
steps we are doing.
And even when we're
calling Google for support,
even when it's them legitimately
touching our buckets
for something that
we've requested,
we have a way of verifying that.
So we are alerted when we get
Access Transparency log access
so that we can say, yeah,
we see that Google accessed
our bucket, which bucket it
was, and which action was taken.
So I want to know that
it was a read action.
I want to know which
bucket they actually read.
And I want to know that it
was based on a support ticket
from us.
So that's really
important for us.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Great.
And I think you've already
sort of started touching
on a little bit of this.
But I just wanted
to know a bit more
about how you've got that
alerting system set up
on your side.
So you're saying
it's alerts that
are coming now from your logs.
LIZ VASQUEZ: So
because, thank god,
you guys thought about
that and already set it up
as Stackdriver Logging.
So we have Stackdriver Logging.
That's fitting into our seam.
And I just noticed
yesterday that--
because we've just started
playing with Security Command
Center--
that you're also
bubbling that up there.
So we also have more plans
of furthering and using
Security Command Center both
within several of our teams.
Obviously, the seam
has use cases where
we can send that to our SOC.
But yeah, for me, it's just
important-- it's, like, we
have all the options.
So we can direct it to our
seam, have use cases there.
Or if someone actually just
wants to use Security Command
Center--
which, we're starting
to figure out
which people we want to give
access to that as well just
so that everybody has
visibility-- that it's also
showing there, which is great.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]